hey youtubers is Charlie so got a whole
bunch of behind-the-scenes clips from
thor ragnarok so I'm gonna play them
Mark Ruffalo even talks about hella a
little bit so this is just going to be a
breakdown of all that stuff important
stuff first so I'll play this hella clip
you can just see her barely walking down
steps but what it lets you know is that
obviously they're going to CG in you
know that big headpiece the antlers and
they're going to make it freakin huge
this teaser that they showed at Comic
Con made it look just like this
production art here so it is just like
bigger than your wingspan is just
enormous you could imagine them asking
Cate Blanchett to film with something
like that like if this was being filmed
thirty years ago and they didn't have
the CG to do something like that they'd
have to have like a crane they carry the
headpiece around while she walked around
with it that's how heavy it would be but
she's one of the most powerful people in
and around Asgard
that is why Odin keeps her stuck in hell
and that's where most of her power is
but I think the movie is gonna blur
those lines just a little bit like she's
someone who was banished by Odin a long
time ago and now she's come back to kick
serious ass
and even though Thor and Hulk are the
big protagonists the film I'm really
hoping for a hell of vs Odin moment like
if Anthony Hopkins isn't going to be in
any more Marvel movies wouldn't it be
awesome to see him go down swinging
against hella with his spear but there's
a whole bunch of other Asgard that
they've been filming these are just some
looks at the sets that they have so
you'll be seeing different parts of
Asgard that you haven't seen in the
previous Thor movies this is like a big
exterior shot from Thor the dark world
so we've actually gotten a pretty good
look at it so far but you just see
different bits of it throughout the
different Thor films it's the same thing
with Game of Thrones like each season
they try to film King's Landing from a
different perspective so when we go back
to Asgard just expect to see parts of it
that you've never seen before it'll be
really exciting and this actually looks
like the set where they dragged hulks
Quinn jet now I don't think that he
crashes in the middle of Asgard like he
crashes somewhere and then it gets
drugged into this city but I think the
idea is is that he took it into space he
crashed on a planet that planet just
happened to be very close to Asgard even
if this isn't Asgard where he crashed
but now I'm going to play a clip from
Mark Ruffalo that'll kind of give you an
idea for the flow of the movie how it's
kind of like a roadtrip comedy uh
I think it'll be smashing um you'll see
a lot more Hulk in this one so get Hulk
it
The Hulk gets Hulk here The Hulk Hulk I
read it yes get the Hulk here and bigger
and the Kate Blanchet gonna be the
villain uh ready yes what do you think
she's gonna bring to that I mean she
plays the worst of the worst
really so evil so she's gonna nail she
is gonna kill it's such a great part you
get the point and and I I'd say it's an
intergalactic buddy road movie with with
banner and Thor if any of you are big
film buffs I would think of this movie
is like Avengers Midnight Run which is
going to take them to a bunch of
different places in outer space like in
the teaser they showed off a comic-con
there were a bunch of spaceships in and
around Asgard things that you normally
wouldn't expect to see it as guard but
amongst the places that they visit it's
rumored that they go to the Kree
homeworld we also know they're coming
back to earth briefly now this looks
like they're coming back because Thor is
on earth too so there are a bunch of
news outlets that we're talking about
road closings where they were getting
ready to film in Brisbane this week so
if you're there you might actually get
to see Chris Hemsworth and Mark Ruffalo
running around filming security is very
tight down here on the ground so lucky
we have the 9 news helicopter up to give
us a behind-the-scenes look but really
the question is which Hollywood
a-listers will come to town come Monday
for the filming of these scenes we know
that Thor 5 definitely has a very
impressive cast list Sir Anthony Hopkins
has actually flown into Australia he was
spotted at Port Macquarie earlier this
week posing with some very excited hotel
staff there we've also seen Mark Ruffalo
holidaying on the Gold Coast but the big
question is will our favorite Chris
Hemsworth pay us a visit
the real question I think is is this
going to be happening at the end of the
movie because they still have a lot of
filming to do for the movie itself but
they film it out of order so they might
be filming stuff that happens later in
the movie earlier in their shooting
schedule and Kevin Feige did confirmed
that they only spend a very very small
amount of time on earth but this looks
like it's going to be doubling for New
York so I would expect all kinds of
Avengers New York jokes
the last time they were in New York was
during Avengers age of Ultron
when vision was born Thor no Thor had
come back in seen that they needed
vision to help them because of the mind
gem so he's like we have to birth this
baby so like he crashes in as the
Avengers start fighting with each other
and charges that birthing chamber with
his hammer then they end up taking off
Thor left them after that adventure that
was the last time he's on earth so this
might be them coming back to New York to
warn the other Avengers about what
they've learned on their big road trip
so it could be happening relatively late
in the film unless something really
weird is happening there's time gem
involved the last time Hulk Thor and
other Thor characters like Loki were in
New York we got this really awesome
moment any time Hulk is on the ground in
a city you usually see stuff like this
like Avengers age of Ultron where he's
smashing the hell out of everything but
if they're only spending a very short
amount of time on earth I wouldn't
expect too much there is one more movie
after Thor Ragnarok before Avengers
infinity war that's black panther each
of the film's kind of moves the timeline
a little bit forward they don't always
move exactly in real time there's
there's so many films are going to be
happening during the same year that I
think they're going to have to wiggle on
that a little bit eventually but under
normal circumstances Black Panthers
happening next so when Thor Ragnarok
ends immediately in the moments after
that the Black Panther movie picks up
like it moves in real time so until we
find out otherwise I would just assume
that's how the timelines moving but
because Black Panther is such a big deal
they're introducing the character I
would only expect loose connections to
the other Avengers films like they'll
acknowledge what happened in civil war
but they won't spend the entire movie
talking about the other films black
panther will have his own problems to
deal with but the other cool thing
that's happening you know we see all
this behind the scenes stuff from these
movies not happening till after Avengers
infinity war which they're getting ready
to start working on but ant-man in the
wasp will also be filming next year so a
lot of these films will be overlapping
with the way they film obviously
Avengers infinity war is the big
crossover movie so I'm hoping to see the
wasp
inside that - we know ant-man is going
to be an infinity war but I'm hoping the
wasp we're shark costume a little bit we
get a teaser for that but if you guys
really like this behind-the-scenes stuff
that they keep dropping every once in a
while just expect a lot more of that
next year because they're going from to
film
a year two Marvel films - three Marvel
films so it almost any given time during
the year they will be filming a Marvel
movie there'll be something new to learn
about the new films that are coming so I
just think that's really exciting so
starting next year going forward there
will be almost no downtime in terms of
big Marvel news about all these movies
so that doesn't even get into the
Netflix series there's almost going to
be three Netflix series a year pretty
soon - because you have so many
different characters each with their own
series then you have the defenders team
up like Punisher is now getting his own
series in addition to the four other
characters that each have their own
series so they just had a daredevil
season three wizard world Chicago panel
I'm going to do a video for that tonight
just talking about daredevil season 3
stuff so be sure to subscribe to get
that there is a new round of the Marvel
giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but even if you're bummed out that
you have to go back to school like what
you know whatever age you are there's
still so much stuff that's going to be
happening in the next month or so and
all the really good TV shows haven't
even come back yet so this is just the
beginning so I know it doesn't seem like
it but there's a ton of awesome stuff
that is happening right now but
daredevil season 3 coming later tonight
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about silk
being in spider-man homecoming and you
can click here for the Avengers infinity
war guardians of the galaxy teaser thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you